[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio daniela blandón dani bienvenida
feliz inicio de semana feliz en mañana
del lunes por supuesto más va a estar
hablando de la economía argentina luego
de las elecciones le pregunto entonces
en términos económicos qué va a pasar
hola raúl buenos días descanso el bien
de semana no no mucho
verdad lo aproveche al máximo bueno
ninguno de nosotros descanso pero lo que
sí estuvimos muy pendientes de las
elecciones en argentina en las que pues
el peronismo que la fuerza que lidera
este país perdió la holgada mayoría que
tenía en el senado en por primera vez en
tres décadas y eso podría dificultar la
agenda económica del gobierno de alberto
fernández por eso el mandatario anunció
que buscará entablar un diálogo con la
oposición lo primero que debe sacar
adelante es un acuerdo para
reestructurar la enorme deuda que tiene
con el fondo monetario internacional de
más de 44 mil millones de dólares y de
la que culpó a su antecesor
el gobierno reveló ser un fracaso en
lugar de cambiar el rumbo se llevaron
tomar esa deuda de 44 mil millones de
dólares con un doble propósito
pagar la deuda insostenible que habían
tomado con acreedores privados y darle
salida a capitales que habían ingresado
al país solo para especular enviaremos
al congreso de la nación un proyecto de
ley que explicite el programa económico
plurianual para el desarrollo
sustentable
este programa contemplará los mejores
entendimientos que nuestro gobierno haya
alcanzado con el staff del fondo
monetario internacional danny le
preguntó entonces qué dicen los
financieros que estamos hablando de una
bebé de 44 mil millones de dólares pues
raúl lo diré según analistas de grandes
firmas como goldman sachs o como 'give y
morgan los inversionistas podrían ver un
lado positivo en esas elecciones y es
que la derrota del peronismo podría dar
paso a políticas económicas más
ortodoxas de las que se vienen aplicando
aunque también existe el riesgo de que
haya políticas más populistas de ahora
en adelante para tratar de conservar
pues el gobierno por eso el gobierno de
alberto fernández ya sacó adelante este
año un polémico impuesto a la riqueza
por ejemplo que no cayó muy bien entre
los empresarios y si entre la población
en general así que veremos qué sucede
cogeremos que sucede seguimos en el sur
de nuestro continente
danny vamos ahora a perú porque como lo
estábamos hablando ya finalmente el
gobierno va a entregar este bono a las
familias de ingresos más bajos y después
de toda la confusión que generó el
presidente como ya la semana pasada el
mandatario había dicho en su discurso de
100 días de gobierno que ningún
trabajador formal iba a ganar menos de
mil soles hablamos de pedro castillo
pero no especificó que lo haría a través
de un subsidio y no de un aumento
salarial en principio se habló de que
serían tres entregas mensuales de 70
soles pero un decreto de urgencia ha
firmado el domingo establece que se haga
un solo pago de 210 soles es decir 52
dólares y aplica para quienes reciban
una remuneración de hasta 2 mil soles lo
que equivale a 500 dólares el ejecutivo
raúl afirma que 3 millones de
trabajadores se verán beneficiados o sea
el 80 por ciento de los empleados
formales pero no olvidemos que esto es
apenas un 10 por ciento en un país de 30
millones de habitantes en donde el 70%
de los empleados son informales como el
empleo informal que tenemos en todos
nuestros países latinoamericanos 40% más
o menos
imagínese el 50 por ciento vamos habrá
china porque será una bolsa de valores
dedicada a los emprendedores en qué
consiste miren se llama beijing stock
exchange se enfoca en lo que llaman los
grandes gigantes raúl veamos
este fue el primer campanazo de la nueva
bolsa que incluye aquellas pequeñas y
medianas empresas dedicadas a la
innovación y chinas y que sabe de eso 81
de ellas ahora están cotizando en el
tercer mercado de valores de china
continental después de shanghai y des
gens en su debut y fue tan aclamado por
los inversionistas que al menos una
decena de empresas según la prensa local
tuvo que suspender operaciones porque en
los primeros minutos los precios de las
acciones llegaron a dispararse hasta en
un 60% raúl ua juego en el curioso no
indicadores sigamos hablando de números
sí señor pues no sólo esta nueva bolsa
de beijing tuvo un excelente inicio de
la semana también lo hizo la mayoría de
las demás bolsas asiáticas animadas por
buenos datos macroeconómicos en china y
en europa las bolsas operan mixtas hay
preocupación sobre el resurgimiento de
casos de kobe 19 como lo veníamos
informando también en nuestro noticiero
y ya para finalizar este primer bloque
de economía le pregunto con qué nos va a
sorprender la cifra del día seguimos en
asia porque un 3% interanual cayó a la
economía de japón en tercer trimestre
mucho más del 0 8% que esperaban los
analistas porque es importante porque es
la tercera economía del mundo que se ve
afectada por la crisis de suministros y
por los nuevos casos de kobe 19 daniela
gracias entonces por ese dato no tan
bueno para la economía japonés y por
supuesto tampoco para la mundial nos
vemos más adelante con más economía en
directo américa ahora vamos a ver
nuestro reportaje